lesnar qui postent des photos dès
l'enfance ase s'amusant c'est un nouveau
challenge qui vient de faire son
apparition sur les réseaux sociaux avec
le hashtag moi disant challenge consiste
à poster à poster des photos de soi à
l'âge de 10 ans l'objectif du projet
s'intéressant à ces soutenir
l'association princesse margot qui vient
en aide aux enfants dans les hôpitaux
dont je vous ai évidemment je vous
invite évidemment à le faire alors d'un
petit juste moi ce que vous allez
reconnaître les stars jeunes voilà par
exemple là alors alors là au milieu
c'est facile alors là oui dans l'ordre
et qui ça kev adams
merci effectivement la photo à 10 ans à
peine facebook permettra du duo est ce
que on en a nommé clio désolé ça tombe
tout le temps je pense que j'ai une
chose cet enfant je ne sais pas moi même
dans leur est pas me dire c'est pas moi
qui fait quoi et vous allez trouver sur
les réponses on n'a pas le temps de
jouer est la suivante me donnez nous les
indices surtout aider mes fils je suis
facile ça ça je sais je sais les
initiales on avait vu que c'est ça ou
pas voilà bah je vais bientôt des photos
il a changé alors encore une et c'est
dangereux que c'est le regard qui ne
change pas les données les initiales au
moins il a alors lui la personne aussi
au cinéma c'est un petit blond à si bon
compte cinq ans c'est lui qui fait baby
lui plaire à vos habits chauds c'est un
ami une dernière alors football alors
oui alors alors alors tu découvres
jamais par ronald ben jama pavard donc
c'est pas mal c'est effectivement
quelqu'un s'est ainsi vu ronaldo
absolument bravo qui sert à ronaldo il
est passé il était déjà pas mal ouais et
maintenant accrochez vous chez vous
parce que là on a fait les stars
maintenant à salir à faire les
chroniqueurs
alors de qui s'agit-il
daniel grasset toi daniel
le plus fou et dieu sait que c'est mon
ami je croise aussi les doigts guillaume
base et des toits et des toits bailly en
robe à celle là alors c'est qu'ils
attendent et c'est qui la photo la
presse et qui le petit blond cible on la
sait qu'il est petit blond c'est qui
mais alors qui est est ce que c'est vrai
c'est en normandie dans la maison de
bâclé qui s'est passé alors guillaume et
abel tabac mail à l'adresse suivante
défense et boa suivant abassan non sa
garde et c'est déjà quelqu'un qui était
cruas et magali c'est magali et oui
cette petite aile arrachée les ailes des
mouches
magali berda jeu suivante les mignonnes
si tu portes une suivante la basse et
l'udc
oui assez luc ces trois ducs et oui
c'est du reste un garçon donc voilà et
on s'achemine dernière on passe à autre
chose qui s'appelle bien-être regardez
bien qu'ils restent au repos
on dirait la dgid pour virer la piste
dans des stratégies web 6 2
mon dieu et l élite et catherine qui a
pas du bruit de photos ces photos je
pense qu'ils ont dû me trouvait trop
moche pour mettre la photo de moi on a
cherché des photos match on n'a pas
trouvé
allez allez vous faisait chez laquelle
[Rires]